hi everyone
um good evening and welcome to
our uh frankie program mapping as
knowing
lecture series we have a wonderful uh
talk this evening
i first wanted to say thanks to all of
you
for joining in and much as we would have
loved to
uh see you all in person and have a
lovely reception afterwards
at the moment we're going to have to
make do with just the company and the
talk
um i wanted to remind you that we are
recording this event
so we request you all to mute your
videos and
uh you can submit questions to the
speaker today
um through the chat feature and so we'll
be reading questions off the chat
and i want to start off by thanking
our benefactors um richard and barbara
frankie
um whose um support
uh of of both the program materially and
of course the intellectual support
um is uh really deeply appreciated
and they plan on joining us i i'm not
sure if
they have entered our room yet um
for today's talk i am utterly delighted
to
introduce our distinguished speaker in
this ongoing series
mapping as knowing and our speaker this
evening
is professor frank snowden professor
snowden is the andrew downey orrick
professor
emeritus of history and history of
medicine and he received his phd
from oxford um he is uh the author of
many critically acclaimed books
including
uh violence and great estates in the
south of italy of puglia
uh 1900 to 1922 which was published in
1984
the fascist revolution in tuscany 1919
to 1922 published in 1989
naples in the times of cholera in 1995
and the conquest of malaria in italy 19
from 1900 to 1962 a book that he
published in 2006.
you might wonder why i'm reading out all
these this is just vicarious pleasure
from just imagining the wonderful field
work experiences that he must have had
in
apulia tuscany naples and now that we're
all stuck
at home i was really um you know
nostalgic nostalgically looking at this
list and wondering
how what it must really be like to
travel again
um his book con the conquest of malaria
was awarded the gustavranes price from
the macmillan center at yale in 2007
as the best book on an international
topic by a member of the yale faculty
um and honored that you all are probably
aware of and the helen and howard
mararo prized by the american historical
association
as the best best work on italy in any
period
he's the recipient of many awards uh
accolades and honors
and i will just mention one in the
interest of not holding you all
up from hearing him this evening and
that is the
2008 welsh medal from the american
association for the history of medicine
he is the author of a brand new book uh
which is extremely topical
and timely um and has been very
influential since its publication just
earlier this year
and the book is titled epidemics in
society
from the black death to the present and
this is published by yale press
um it's wonderfully written book and i
strongly encourage you
to uh to buy it and as you can see from
the record of his scholarship and his
research
that you know epidemics he has deep
insights on epidemics
and our ability or lack of ability to
manage them
so he has um today um
he will be uh talking to us about
maps and epidemics in particular uh
lessons
for the current pandemic for covid19 he
also teaches undergraduate and graduate
courses in italian history european
social and political history
and the history of medicine before i
hand over to him i just wanted to remind
you about a couple of upcoming frankie
events
the next talk in our series on the
mapping is knowing series is going to be
by the musicologist victor coelho and
that's going to be next
term you will all uh hear about it we'll
send you
uh the poster and details
uh later on and i was very excited to
announce that you know
the frankie program had announced a
contest called eureka
which in light of the pandemic we have
had to reimagine
and we have re-imagined it as a new
project which we call
learning by doing which we are launching
next week
it is a set of simple science
experiments
for kids that they can do with their
parents
and we are planning to offer videos of
these experiments we'll be collecting
ideas
and we have a website so please watch
out for
a website www.learningbydoing.academy i
will share further information in just a
minute
and without further ado i would um
like to turn it over to professor
snowden to speak
to us we are eagerly waiting to learn
from you
about maps and epidemiology in
particular
lessons for this uh kovit 19 which has
completely destabilized our world at the
moment
professor snowden oh well thank you so
much
i thank all of you for joining me this
afternoon
and it's a great pleasure to be here i
wish also to thank the whitney
humanities center and the frankie
lecture series
uh for inviting me and especially i want
to thank you
uh for the very generous introduction i
was going to say
awarded to about myself that i think
that the organizers know me much better
than i know myself so uh since that's no
longer necessary
i'll just begin and i'd like to say what
my plan is
first this afternoon what i'd like to do
is to consider the relationship
between historical mountain making on
the one hand
and the emergence of epidemiology on the
other
my idea in particular is to begin by
considering
one of the most influential maps in the
history of medicine
the famous map of the london-based
physician
jon snow he did in fact
draw two maps and they've been called
maps that changed the history of the
world
they helped to unlock the mystery of
asiatic cholera as a disease
these were maps that also related
to the pandemic that afflicted london in
1854
the first and i can perhaps show that
now
is a map that was a detailed map of a
single
neighborhood the neighborhood of soho
in london the second map is a map that's
the one
uh is the map uh that i won't actually
be showing
but i won't talk a little bit about it
it details the relationship
between the disease cholera and the
provision of water
to south london by two different and uh
water companies well having then
explored what snow demonstrated by his
cartography
i want to leap forward in time to
covid19
thinking about what we can learn about
the epidemiology
of this pandemic by considering a series
of 239 don't panic i'm not planning to
show you them all
but 239 maps produced by the united
states government
in the 1930s maps that impose
very important questions about the
nature
of the coronavirus and the ways in which
it is laid bare
the way that social injustice itself is
a very important
pathway through which this disease is
making its way
through our country now let's remember
when we talk about joan snow
uh what the understanding of asiatic
cholera
was at the time when he was carrying out
his work
at that time the international medical
profession
had two different views regarding what
cholera might be
the dominant view was one uh that was
a view that this was not
a contagious view a disease it was an
anti-contagionist view
it argued that cholera was not
transmitted
uh from person to person in any sort of
way
but in some undefined way it was
produced by a poisoning of the air
called a miasma the miasma originated
from decaying
organic matter in filth and the miasma
arose as a deadly effluvium
that susceptible people inhaled and fell
ill in england it was time
very much common by medical authorities
to refer to malaria that is
bad air or they also talked about
the filth theory of disease that is to
say
whole categories of disease including
cholera
were thought to be non-contagious
contagionism the idea of an
infectious disease was a minority view
but the one that jon snow himself had
espoused he believed that cholera was
not a masmatic
disease at all but was transmitted
person to person
via the medium of contaminated water
in 1849 he had already written a book
on the mode of communication of cholera
before
his famous mounts and there he
unoutlined
his objections to my asthmatism and
proposed instead what he saw
as the more plausible interpretation of
contagion
but he lacked convincing evidence and
couldn't suggest
the mechanisms above all that were
involved
in his idea of transmission so the major
outbreak of 1854 provided him with the
occasion
to do very careful detective work and to
produce
two maps uh the first of which we might
return to
this map is the neighborhood
of soho in 1854
now soho experienced at that time an
intense
local outbreak in the neighborhood that
cholera was what he called
the worst disease in the history of the
kingdom
at the time soho had no sewer system
it had no secure supply of water
and most houses had recourse to suspects
and residents collected water for
drinking
and for their ablutions in buckets
from a pump well and that pump well is
where the red
arrow in the map is in broad street
located at the center of the district
now snow's suspicions focused on the
pump
and to test his idea he carried out
careful detective work
mapping cases of cholera these are spot
maps
and each of the black um areas
that you see uh represents cases of
cholera
in the neighborhood of soho and a number
of
features clearly stood out the first was
that the nearer people were to the pump
the more likely a house
was to have cases of cholera a second
was that people who depended on the pump
for their drinking water
fell ill first of all
then there were some puzzling factors
that took quite a bit of detective work
there were 10 puzzling cases of people
who lived nearby and fell ill of cholera
but never took water from the pump but
it turned
out that they ate meals
at a restaurant nearby and the
restaurant served
not only food but it served its diners
uh water fresh from the broad street
pump
then there was another puzzle was that
there was a jail nearby
and somehow none of the 200 prisoners
had fallen ill with cholera at all
it turned out that in fact the prison
uh brought in water from a distant
source
and so the prisoners didn't drink water
at all
and then by an interview with a local
minister
in soho what jon snow
learned was a crucial further fact that
is
the minister pointed into what modern
epidemiologists
might call patient zero it turned out
that a local woman
who'd been away from the area had
contracted cholera
but then recovered she returned to soho
with her toddler
who also fell violently ill she disposed
of the infant's diapers
in a cesspit with forced walls
located just a few feet from the well
itself
so snow examined the well water and
discovered white flakes
floating in it that he thought were the
pathogenic material
now we know uh from modern
studies and our knowledge of the
symptomatology of cholera
that it produces the famous rice water
stools
which are in fact the blood plasma
being drawn out of the water out of the
um the intestinal system and along with
that
some of the lying of the intestinal
lumen
which actually is the white flakes that
snow discovered
well having rapidly collected and mapped
his findings
snow was able to overcome the resistance
of local authorities
to try a further experiment which was to
deactivate
the suspect well in broad street by
removing the pump handle
and when they finally concurred
they removed the handle and the disease
immediately ceased well
retrospectively after this epidemic
uh snow continued his research this time
doing detective work in south london
not all of london relied on hand pumps
and welds
some districts were served by private
water companies
and snow drew up a map i'll leave you to
imagine that you can just imagine
a map of the city of london with a river
coursing through and then various areas
on the south side of the river
with different colors for different
districts
that were supplied by different water
companies
well it turns out there were two in
particular the lambeth water company
and the southwark and vauxhall water
company
and whether you received water from one
or the other
made a tremendous difference in what
happened to you
the lambeth well the let's start with
the southwark
and vauxhall water company it served 40
000 houses and it yielded 1213 cases of
cholera
or 315 for every 10
000 houses served the southwark
and vauxhall water company drew its
water
from the river thames long after it had
begun
its pathway through the city and after
the residents of london had already
disposed of their waste
in its waters the lambeth company
by contrast drew its water upstream
before it had entered the city
and it produced just 98 cases of cholera
for 27 000 houses that is a rate
of 37 for every 10 000 houses
versus 315 for the other water company
so the impact of snow's map
was very very important the two maps
marked the foundation of the discipline
of epidemiology
and show the utility of spot maps
they also had a very practical impact on
the sanitary movement
that was just then getting its underway
in britain
it gave a boost to contagionism as well
although the medical profession remained
skeptical
and said this was a matter of
correlation
rather than causation and they complain
that
snow had yet to stop to discover uh
the actual pathogen itself
to prove his case and that in fact we
now know
required the development in the next
generation
of microscopy as a field of research
but snow's hypothesis was ultimately
confirmed
by the work of pasteur and robert konk
marking the triumph of the germ theory
of disease
by the 1880s and for our purposes
a feature that's very important is that
it demonstrated in practice
the power of map making for medical
science
the application in fact of some of the
tools of the humanities
in this case illustration and
storytelling
because that's what the maps were doing
they were telling a narrative
to elaborating the scientific
understanding
of this deadly disease the most feared
disease
of the 19th century well now i'm going
to fast forward
and return again to the 21st century
and begin with my third map which is
uh that i want to talk about which would
be the next slide if i
could have that uh this is um
a map this is the one uh it's one of the
300 239 maps
that i warned you about and relax
because this is the only one
i'm actually going to show you it had
two wives
and had two very different but powerful
impacts
on our country the first impact
was during the 1930s when
these maps served the purpose
of an enormous plan of social
engineering
carried out by the new deal in the and
the united states government
in the 1930s for purposes that are now
recognized
as profoundly racist more recently
these maps have been resurrected and
have provided an
understanding of vital aspects of the
current
coronavirus pandemic in our country
they have followed investigative
methods various uh commentators
uh various methods highly reminiscent
of snow's methodology and the 19th
century
now this particular map is a map
of on the 1930s
of philadelphia and you'll note the
different
uh colored areas on it
the maps were
demonstrate that
considering these maps is worthy of a
frankie
lecture because they bring together
disciplines
that normally remain in separate
disciplinary silos
i'm thinking of environmental science
history
epidemiology and cartography
and the maps also raise urgent
and practical questions of politics
ethics and public health what lessons
do we learn from covid19 about its
origins
and capacity to spread in our midst
how do we learn enough both to emerge on
the other side of this pandemic
and to prepare ourselves for future
epidemic challenges
by removing the crucial vulnerabilities
that caught us so unprepared at the
start of 2020
and then there's a great question of
ethics
and how we deal with what we learn
a great interest of pandemics i believe
is that they are among other things
great moral dramas
taking place before our lives and
laying there the nature of our
relationships to one another
pandemics are not random they reflect
the nature
of the society we have built and they
travel on pathways
that we ourselves have constructed for
them
as they make their way through our midst
if those ideas are correct
then what do we see in this particular
reflection of ourselves that we'll see
in this map and what ethical and
political imperatives
do we feel to change the picture
now that we're still plunged in the
midst of our tragedy
this may indeed be the best time to
reflect on how we got here
and what needs to change to make our
society
covid proof for the next generation
but first of all let's turn to the maps
uh they're now fairly well known this is
one of the collection the collection was
discovered in the national archives
and they have now all been digitized and
are presently housed
at the university of richmond and are
available
online their purposes and impact
have also been explored most notably
recently
by richard rothstein and his wonderful
book
the color of law and also by tah
nahizi coates now the means
these maps were the means to implement
as i said a vast program of social
engineering
by the new deal in other words franklin
roosevelt and his administration
to combat the great depression and boost
housing construction
and to improve the
living standards of the poor and working
classes
by a redistribution of wealth that set
up
three federal agencies that were
interrelated
and all had to do with housing the
public works administration
set up in 1933 the homeowner's loan
corporation of the same year
and the fha the federal housing
administration
in 1934 these carried out
an enormous redistribution of wealth
to promote construction and home
ownership
that was at this time considered the
embodiment of the american dream
and a bulwark against possible left-wing
subversion
as homeowners it was argued would never
risk communism
and social subversion but at the same
time
the roosevelt administration fully
embraced
american racial hierarchies and intended
to institutionalize
and reinforce segregation billions of
federal dollars
were deployed to rescue distressed
white homeowners or aspiring white
homeowners
by means of cheap government-backed
mortgages
and insurance to that end the cheap
mortgages
under the program were not to be
available to african americans
and the maps were the means to implement
that vision
the homeowners loan corporation
commissioned maps therefore of every
major
city and town in the country 239 in all
and it's important to stress that these
were carried out
not just in the south but in the north
as well
and this is a good example it's a map of
philadelphia
in these maps each neighborhood
of each city was graded and
shaded and then coded for the purpose
of qualifying applicants for mortgages
and insurance
and the coding provided direction for
the entire mortgage and insurance
industry
banks savings institutions savings and
loan associations
insurance companies green earned you
a grade of a this marked the best
neighborhoods
where only whites were intended to live
in single-family houses
and were subsidized and insured
mortgages were to be made available
we should realize that these maps
were not simply descriptions of
uh what existed they were prescriptions
of what was intended to be so
uh the next below the green uh
was blue a grade of b these were also to
be
lilly white but they were less desirable
areas lower down the yellow areas on the
map
earn a grade of c they were somewhat
hazardous
for investors areas that perhaps had
what documents accompanying the maps
called
unwelcome i'm quoting here unwelcome
infiltrations of negroes and
foreign-born
people and the mixing and i'm quoting
again
of inharmonious ethnic groupings
and then at the bottom there's red the
grade of
d and this is the area where loans
investments and insurance were all to be
rigidly discouraged this the red zones
gave rise to the term redlining but as
you can see
the neighborhood divisions are actually
outlined
in black and the term therefore is
slightly appropriate
the areas are distinguished by shading
in the relevant colors so the maps
were proscriptive the color codes
were intended to regularize segregation
and housing
on a permanent basis and in fact they
were eminently successful in that
and that's precisely what they achieved
and the racial and nativist vision
involved
was in no way hidden each map was
accompanied
by a one-page appraisal document
that specified that negroes and
foreign-born
undesirables were not eligible for loans
and home ownership and that investment
in the area
was officially discouraged furthermore
the homes purchased were to provide in
their property deed
what were termed restrictive covenants
that is
clauses that in perpetuity excluded the
sale of the property
to african americans these clauses had
already been tested
in 1926 before the supreme court
which pronounced such covenants legal
and constitutional
so segregation was meant to be permanent
throughout the land
and informally on a local basis in both
north and south
attempts by african americans other
professional classes
to break the color wall and to move into
areas that were not
shaded in the proper color were often
met
with violence riot and fire as we know
for example
from the cicero neighborhood of chicago
and this shows us that racism isn't
simply a matter of attitudes
the whites of cicero when they attacked
african americans knew full well
that the arrival of an african-american
family in their midst
meant a recoding of the area and
therefore
a precipitous fall in property values
racism therefore was a legal and
financial structure
and not just an attitude but
now he will be wondering how are the
maps relevant
to covet 19 to understand that
we need to realize that the racial
segregation
engineered in the 1930s is a structural
racist
vision that persists to this very day
during the pandemic there is federal
reserve bank of chicago for example
noted in a study in 1910 that the
pattern of racial disparity
established by redlining was persisting
80 years after it been first proposed
in terms of segregation homeownership
ratios
house values and credit ratings and in
fact
one could go further than the federal
reserve of chicago
by saying that actually the position had
worsened
rather than improving that is to say
after world war ii we see the great
suburbanization of america
that was funded by the gi bill and the
veterans administration
and this again redistributed billions of
dollars
to white veterans to purchase new homes
but again not to african americans
however bravely they had fought in the
war
the legal and lending practices of the
1930s
originally confined to the cities were
now
exported also to suburbia complete
with the restrictive covenants and we
get closer to public health and disease
by noting that the new deal housing
program
and the veteran administration program
after world war
ii were powerful engines of economic
disparity
and the creation of poverty it's not by
coincidence
that the wealth possessed by the average
african
family today in the united states
is five percent of that owned by the
average white
family what that means
is that there has been a subsidized
publicly subsidized and persistent
equity and homeownership from the 1930s
onward that has been directed
towards particular racial groups and
denied
others this was a decisive creator of
wealth and african americans were
systematically
and purposefully deprived of access to
it
as well as those wealth creating
mechanisms
of the tax laws that provided deductions
for mortgage payments and the
inheritance laws
that enabled accumulated wealth to be
passed with little risk
from generation to generation let me
give you an example
let me turn to the very
ideal type of the new suburbia
that emerged after world war ii the very
first
great suburban community that is
levittown
and nassau county new york there
seventeen thousand homes were built i
should
note too that they were intentionally
built by non-unionized labor
and during the construction the building
builders
were picketed they were offered in 1957
for a sale at seven thousand nine
hundred
and ninety dollars we can say were
offered because these houses
were pre-fabricated they were assembled
in 26
pieces and each one was identical
a cape or a ranch to all of those
on the surrounding block so they were
for sale
all at once for seven thousand nine
hundred and ninety dollars each
made available however to veterans
at four hundred dollars now in 2018
the exact same pre-fabricated homes
were worth an average of 400 000
so you can see the enormous accumulation
in equity between 1957
and 2020 and realize what
uh the way in which uh the wealth of
white families
was publicly subsidized and denied to
african americans
as we know in the area shaded in red
african americans continued to languish
in multi-family dilapidated inner city
neighborhood
well in night there were some
countervailing influences
the supreme court in 1948 declared the
restrictive covenants
of violation of the 14th amendment and
the fair housing act
of 1968 made redlining illegal in the
mortgage industry
but in practice the old structures
remained
and were not dismantled so the former
redlined neighborhoods are today's
inner city ghettos the very ones that
were ravaged
by the coronavirus we could say then
that the red shadings on the maps of the
1930s
still define the islands of
vulnerability
to infectious disease and death and
2020.
i would like to show the last
show and tell that i'm going to present
which is
um follows the map that i showed
you won't be able to see it very well
i'm afraid
the point is that this is one of the
appraisal documents
that accompanied the maps each mount
had this document along with it
explaining
what the neighborhood was meant to look
like
and we'll see for example this is will
be familiar to you all
it's a d-rated neighborhood in new haven
connecticut
and it goes along um golf
whaley and dixwell avenues as far as
sherman avenues
and in the 1930s it tells us that the
inhabitants there
were domestics and that they were
predominantly negro
there's even a line to tell if you're
negro or foreign born
that is the nativism and the racism it's
70 percent negroes
and there's in growing it says
infiltration
negroes are infiltrating the area
and it tells us that these are houses
that are predominantly multi-family
and not single owner occupied
and at the bottom for clarifying remarks
it says this is an older section of the
city
which has now given over largely to
negroes
employed as domestics dwelling
very from small
singles and to multi-family the
this is quite congested as an area
and it gives uh the appearance of a slum
area there's an absence of market forces
that has resulted in some demolitions
and the section is subject to vandalism
and we'll see that its prediction for
the future
is that it's going to decline further
and it says
is there any availability of mortgage
and this was a self-fulfilling prophecy
of none so uh that's uh just to show you
that this was a very intentional plan
and that
the racial narrative was completely
built into the structure of the plan
now the reasons for the disparities
today
and vulnerability to covet 19
are not all of course attributable to
the legacy of structural racism
but that goes a long way to explaining
what's happening today in our midst some
of the sources of vulnerability
are not immediately related school
segregation for example
means that houses are underfunded and
schools
provide people with the knowledge that
they need to protect themselves
access to medical care uh has to do
with insurance or underinsurement or
under insurance and also with the legacy
of distrust
between the african-american community
and the medical profession
which emerged so starkly as a result of
the tuskegee experiment
we could talk also about unemployment
and
wages about types of work about diet
and the widespread presence of
obesity and diabetes that are
predisposing factors
for covid19 and one could extend the
list
but what i would like to do is to note
how many
factors are related to what was done
in the 1930s and confirmed after world
war
ii the first point is that the housing
stock
in the inner cities as we all know has
been poorly maintained
and often unhygienic that there's
multiple
family occupancy multiple generation
occupancy as well and we know that
covid19 makes its way preferentially
among elderly bodies and also
that it's in disease a viral disease
spread by droplets and aerosols through
the air
and therefore it thrives on conditions
of density
and these are densely packed
multi-family
multi-generational houses we also know
that uh african-american homes
these neighborhoods had a shortage
of amenities and some were actually have
been
often disconnected such as water
in our country as a disproportionate
number
of families without household water
supplies
and therefore unable to practice hand
washing
the advan one of the major bits of
advice
for coping with covet 19 and
also because of the density of incapable
of practicing social distancing another
major factor is environmental
and this is directly relating related
and built upon
the social engineering of the new deal
that is green and red
shaded neighborhoods actually constitute
different ecological environments
uh one feature is uh that's
most important is air pollution
by air pollution i mean on the one hand
greenhouse gases that is ground
level ozone or the various oxides of
nitrogen
emitted by cars by
heating industry refineries
power plants decaying tires landfills
and recently here at yale there's been a
discovery
of the vital importance of urban land
use
that is to say in a great a neighborhood
there were not what you find in a green
neighborhood uh in a grade d red
neighborhood
you would not find the amenities of a
grade a
neighborhood in terms of large yards
parks
trees instead in the inner cities
approximately 50 percent of the land
is covered in asphalt for roads roofs
and driveways
and in the heat they emit enormous
amounts of greenhouse gases
and global warming is making the
position worse
it's generating what are called
heat islands in the center of the cities
that are 5 to 20 degrees fahrenheit
warmer than the a-rated areas were
and then their fine and ultra fine
particulate matter
part of particulate matter generated by
industry cold burning wildfires
construction and
demolition crumbling plaster and all the
rest
and it's interesting to note the
sighting of industry
was in part dependent on the zoning
the red lining of the 1930s
that is to say that the most noxious
fuel producing industries and services
were are called fence line
industries directly adjacent
to a d-rated neighborhood
that is to say there were areas where
the land was
cheaper for placement where there are
probably highways
nearby there were low transaction costs
it was easy and cheap to get zoning
permission
with little opposition from impoverished
residents
with little political power south
philadelphia
on the map i showed you before is south
philadelphia
is a vast sea of red on the map
and the point is that it was a fence
line community
inhabited by african americans it's
located
next to the largest oil refinery
until last year in the east of the
united states
it has incinerators sewage treatment
plants
power plants and chemical companies none
of which you see
in the blue and white
shaded areas to the top of the map the
n-double set up a clean air
task force in which it noted that
african americans
are 75 percent more likely to live
in a fence-line community than a white
american
and that they are on average exposed
to more than 50 percent more air
pollution
on a constant base basis
now air pollution is a leading cause
of death worldwide seven million
people around the globe die prematurely
every year from the impact of air
pollution according
to the world health organization and
that is
more people than perish from malaria tb
hiv aids and warfare all combined
these pollution generates
stroke asthma heart disease
respiratory infections and obstructive
lung diseases
cancers but air pollution is also a
specific
cause of vulnerability to covid19
a source of the very comorbidities that
lead to severe
death and to severe disease
a fine particulate matter destroys
the cilia of the upper respiratory
pathways and it causes inflammation
in the inner respiratory tract of
bronchioles
and alveoli and recent research
has done what snow did which was
uh carried out at harvard in the
netherlands
and in the po valley uh in italy
they have demonstrate followed snow's
mythology
of superimposing maps of covid mortality
and morbidity over
the counties in the united states and
the administrative districts in
europe that had the worst air pollution
unfortunately these maps aren't
available for public use at the moment
and so we'll just have to imagine
something like
what snow did and there's it turns out
that there's a direct correlation just
as in the case of the broad street pump
and the south water companies in south
london
between uh these vulnerabilities
and to um disease
particularly the infectious disease
cholera and snow's case
covered 19 and ours and then
pathology physiological studies
are increasingly demonstrating direct
mechanisms especially that of
inflammation
that are directly related to
vulnerability to covid19
so now that i'm running rapidly out of
time
i think it would be wise to note that
uh with a hopeful note up towards the
end
that we are waiting now for a vac soon
scene that will soon arrive but i do
want to make
a caveat at the same time it's important
for us to remember
that both for covid19 and even more
perhaps for the future we need to
address
social determinants of disease that are
critical
to our preparedness this should happen
in part because it's right but also
because
the pandemic has demonstrated that is
also an
act of enlightened self-interest
all of us in other words are in this
together
and if some communities are especially
high risk
everyone else will also be in danger
now map making reminds us
what paul farmer has eloquently said
that medicine and public health need to
focus
not only on molecular level phenomena
but need to give due attention to social
factors
and make structural interventions that
doctors
nurses and public health workers are in
fact
the natural advocates of the poor
the disadvantaged and the racially
oppressed
so i think that this is a practical
public health
and a moral imperative that
faces us and i hope that as a country
um even after the vaccine has
done its work we'll remember what got us
into this situation in the first place
and remember
that this is almost certainly not
the last challenge from viral
disease that we'll be facing and that we
need to be prepared
in the future and not allow
an unnecessary suffering and disaster
that has ravaged our communities
over this past year now if people have
um questions or uh
objections or questions that would be
wonderful
uh thank you very much for that really
uh thoughtful and
um illuminating talk uh i think the chat
is open
uh please uh go ahead and um
type in um your questions
and i guess while we wait for that um i
might just
uh go ahead and um ask you
um a question uh myself
i think that you know it's it is very
clear historically as you showed
that the patterns of human settlement
and socio-economic
inequalities that undergird that really
do
shape the way in which diseases
propagate if you could think of
one thing that we could do
as a society at the policy level
what would it be after covet 19.
obviously you know inequities in society
you know economic inequalities have
really become much starker
in the last couple of decades um
do you think that it is uh time now to
seriously address that because it is
going to be
it would offer the backdrop for any
future pandemics or
any kinds of other uh catastrophes
that are not individual tragedies but
you know if climate change induced
catastrophes as well
i was curious if you had advice for
policy makers as to what would be
a key intervention now in light of what
we've learned so far
right um i think that uh since you've
limited me to one
intervention
and say that i would think of one that
addresses directly
the issue of care and
the issue of poverty and that is and
i'll be following here
what dr tagerus director general of the
world health organization said
which is uh i then share with him the
view
that perhaps the decisive intervention
is universal health care for everyone i
think
that addresses the issue of poverty and
it directly
addresses the ins uh the problem
of widespread disease so if there were
one
kind of if i could wave my magic wand
and do one thing i think that would be
the number one thing that i would do
that would transform
uh american life and uh the safety
of the american people
thank you now that that makes uh total
sense
that you know making uh universal access
to health care healthcare
a basic human right that is guaranteed
by all polities
there are various ways to do that and so
i'm not
saying exactly which way has to be
the one but i think the point is that
everyone in the world needs to have
a human right the human right to health
care
and to free access universal access
to that health and that it shouldn't be
determined
as a matter of profit
our first question that's our job yeah
go ahead
please sure considering this issue of
redlining
uh concerning that it's close to a
century old now what do you see
in our future not just for disease but
for equity
oh um i feel that i don't
know what lies in our future i guess i'm
professionally
uh forbidden if you like as a historian
uh
to uh have a crystal ball and uh
say what will happen in the future but
since you've uh
you've raised the question i'll i will
give something
uh of a very who knows what will happen
that's my
first point nobody knows and a lot will
be determined
about whether as in 1918 to 19
we decide we want to put this behind us
and not think about it anymore and
that was the approach then i my
hope is that this has been
such a long lasting and will have been
uh by the time
it's over such a cataclysmic economic
as well as medical crisis that
hopefully hopefully we will
be wise enough to realize that this
must not happen also to our children and
grandchildren
we must leave a safer world for the
future
that's more sustainable and therefore
part of that
is it has to do with confronting
the great inequalities that our
society is built upon that didn't arise
naturally but were part of a consciously
devised
social engineering project uh it's not i
think which is one of the more
shocking uh realizations that comes from
examining these maps of the 1930s
that what they created is still the way
that we live today
and therefore i think that there really
does
need to be uh maybe there's some
talk uh myself i'm a bit of a here i'll
reveal my own
beliefs but i guess i believe in some
sort of form
of green new deal in which we tackle
environmental issues that are critical
for the survival of the planet and for
its survival of our country
and the disadvantaged in it and also
provide employment and all the rest
for everyone in the country
and devising new ways i would like to
see
that happen i suppose if i had were
allowed
a second magic wand uh that would
probably be
the thing i do second uh and we know
that
sometimes genies give you three wishes
um
but my genie first gave me just one and
you've given me a second so that's good
thank you another participant has
mentioned
uh the work of cartographers on the
redlining that you've been discussing
he notes that there's a session i guess
the zoom session tomorrow
uh by the chicago map society on the
very subject and
i think they're as i'm reading this
correctly a documentary that's been
produced called redlined
um especially on this topic well let me
thank um
uh the person who suggested that i would
love uh love to see it
and um i'd like to know more about the
cartography
involved and who the people involved
were who actually drew up the mounts
i know who commissioned them but i don't
know who
actually produced them okay great
um just getting another question here
i think there's a question uh from uh
who says thank who thanks you for the
talk the amazing talk
and asks um that she read somewhere that
san francisco was somewhat better
prepared than the rest of the country
for covet because of their experience
with aids in the 1980s
and she just wanted to ask you you know
is that
really true and um
and whether the ghost of aids is
haunting the covet crisis in some way
um i would say that there are a couple
of answers
to that question one of which is that i
don't really know but from what
bits and pieces i do know i would say
there's
more than one piece to that uh
particular puzzle
one reason is that in san francisco
um there were one of the another major
driver
of disadvantaged people in this pandemic
has been the elderly and the elderly in
nursing homes in particular
and the disease uh i would say that
ageism is also systematically and
structurally
built into our system and that the
nursing homes as the new england journal
of medicine
of peace there just in the last few
weeks said that they were like
tinder boxes waking for a spark to be
struck
that they were systematically unprepared
and indeed unpreparable
well um the point is that san francisco
had a number of nursing homes that were
radically different that were part of
the imagination of a greenhouse project
which has small nursing
care centers of perhaps 10
member residents of a community with
nurses who actually live on site and
therefore
are not going back and forth inside the
community
don't have multiple jobs and so on
and therefore the kind of care and the
oversight
practice in san francisco were quite
exceptional
in the american context and i do believe
that uh it is true that a number of
places
by having experience this is true not
only of san francisco but
internationally
one of the reasons for example in africa
and a number of countries there was that
they had been prepared
by a whole series of uh calamities
from the past including ebola that we
all
remember and were in a sense uh
expecting
more ready to accept and expect
something like this or
a place um like it was important that
korea south korea had had the experience
of merge
and going back further on san francisco
there were still community health
centers
and that really do those do really
make health care more accessible to
disadvantaged communities
than a huge uh city with a
huge urban hospital miles away
that takes an a person without a car an
hour to reach by a long
uh bus ride so um i think the
those are features uh i don't believe
that that is in any way
an adequate answer to the question but
those are some features
that i think are parts of it
yes while we um wait for more questions
i
i was curious whether you had thoughts
about now that we do have
um the prospect of multiple vaccines
you know the distribution of these
vaccines and how that is going to be set
up in terms of
access and equity issues is also kind of
front and center
um that's that's absolutely correct
and we don't um quite know we have the
cdc
recommendations of how the various
tiers that should
that the vaccine distribution should
follow and we know
uh from the cdc's uh announcement that
this will be
months and months and months actually uh
uh will be required before it reaches
um let us say you and me um uh
in the community so that is a very
fundamental and important
ethical um and practical question it
seems
from every point of view that the cdc
recommendation
is right that healthcare workers ought
to be protected first
uh we depend on them and they are in
some ways they are the heroes or
among the heroes of this pandemic and
they desperately
need to be protected uh
while they carry out this work that's
essential
to our whole nation so i i accept
that as a good first priority
thinking historically and with your
expertise in italy considered
in the cities of europe what what were
the fault lines
along which such segregation might have
occurred
um the the front lines are sometimes a
little bit
similar and reminiscent it is
true that um african
asian communities in britain
very disproportionately uh experienced
severe disease and mortality
in in britain
it's true elsewhere that immigrant
communities
were were quite vulnerable but
it's interesting too and this goes back
to another feature
which is that not everywhere was the
disease
primarily a matter of poverty and i
think
if you look at the second after china
the second great because you mentioned
italy the second great epicenter in the
world
uh was lombardi in the north of italy
and what's interesting about lombardy
is that uh it was
the most prosperous region of italy and
one of the great prosperous regions of
the world
but there i would say it was
overwhelmingly
a disease of globalization because
lombardy and china
had established a bilateral agreement
in 2016 that led to
enormous investment between the two
countries
cultural exchange three and a half
million chinese tourists
visited milan every year after the
agreement was signed
there were chinese lessons there were um
entrepreneurs
politicians went back and forth there
were affairs
between the two countries exhibiting the
goods of each country
so when uh the epidemic broke out in
china
probably the least surprising thing that
could have happened
was that it would uh next be present
in lombardy and there were even
six direct flights um the airlines that
did direct flights between
the mall pensa airport uh in milan
and a number of chinese cities so this
movement of people
goods services investment was constant
and overwhelming
and meant that a disease that was
infectious and had broken out in wuhan
would be in one day would be in
milan the next and indeed that's rather
uh how it was and uh this was not
prior it then did not follow it followed
lines of housing and multi-family
occupancy
and density rather than anything
corresponding
to the american ethnicity issue
i guess globalization um plays a big
role today
in terms of transmission of disease and
is very much
part of um yes in fact if i were to be
asked to define
uh what kind i say that
diseases reflect particular stages in
the development of our societies that we
humans make the diseases have no agency
we create the pathways that pathogens
find
to reach us and i would say that uh this
is the first
great pandemic of the era of
globalization
and uh that if we understand it in that
way
globalization includes uh enormous
international trade and exchange
tourism displaced people uh enormous
overpopulation mega cities and high
density
and it includes all of the environmental
problems that we were talking about
plus one would also that is to say
about pollution and all the rest of it
but one would also have to invoke
our relationship with the other
creatures that inhabit our planet
deforestation and the destruction of
animal
habitat which if we remember how this
disease
began it's a zoonotic disease that
spread from bats to human beings
now there was nothing wrong with the
bats it was that human beings were
increasingly
invading and destroying their habitat
and came into contact with them
in ever-growing measures and so this
there were
continuous spillover events and those
eco-health alliance has been doing a
very interesting work
or was doing very interesting work until
the nih grant to continue it
was cut off by our president um
but hopefully they'll start doing it
again uh and
the monitoring of that situation
is uh quite an important one because
bats
are enormously part of the reason china
has played such a role is that bats are
so numerous
there and they are so um
uh they're the reservoir for
countless viruses and they are wonderful
at roosting in vast numbers
and transmitting the disease to which
they're immune
from one species or one member uh a
fellow species to another
and so bats are really very important
and then of course
china was important because of uh its
density
uh and those sorts of issues there are
lots of other reasons
uh pollution is also very important
there
and mega cities are important and
uh even the wet markets are important
there
so there are a host of reasons that
china
happened to be the place that was first
struck
none of which are equivalent to saying
it was the chinese disease there was
nothing
about chinese people it was about
certain
uh developmental and ecological features
of the chinese environment that were
important
thank you two more questions there have
been studies that show that some
communities that have higher mortality
are actually genetically predisposed to
be vulnerable to the virus shouldn't
these
also be considered a priority
um to the extent to which that is
actually so uh they clearly should be
and here i'll have to say that i myself
don't know
enough about genetic predisposition to
covet 19
to say anything sensible about it so it
would probably be better
if i say if i can look into that
learn more about it and then i can give
you an answer
but i better not do that right now
from professor valerie hanson who
started our
series this semester she says frank are
there any instances
either in the past or with covid in
which the disease
strikes in surprising ways for instance
for example
where any rich communities hit hard or
did any localities with non-dense
housing
still suffer greatly uh yes there
are these um uh instances uh
a first thing is that uh these epidemic
diseases
are by no means a simple repetition of
the same thing
happening again and again each is
entirely different
so there are diseases that have
particularly
targeted the poor cholera is clearly one
on the other hand the spanish influenza
is
uh probably the opposite of the disease
that struck
every social class that didn't have this
particular
predisposition but swept uh through
entire communities and i was would even
venture to say
that covid19 can manifest itself
in different ways and lombardy was a
case
in which it affected a very prosperous
community and not a very impoverished
one
so that's uh a clear example of that and
we also have cases
where covet 19 began by striking
in rural communities
and the netherlands and the eastern
agricultural
areas of the netherlands are an example
of that
and there have been dutch studies of
that
and one of the features has to do with
the overwhelming
um air pollution let me ask them to
i was just going to say the northern
area of the netherlands
as an advanced highly developed
um industrialized agriculture
uh produces enormous amounts of animal
waste
and uh nitric nitrogen oxides
so that's one of the features that
proved to be
um really important in the epidemiology
of that and so it's again a bit
different
from uh what i've been just talking
about but yes
there are varieties in epidemic disease
and i think that's part of the uh their
interest that
it's they reveal a lot about history
and studying them teach us a lot about
how communities are put together
i think that brings us to the end
doesn't it time
i think so yes so i just wanted to say
thanks thank you so much tai
for helping with this as always
and thank you so much professor snowden
for a wonderful talk
about really important topics that we
now need to think about
now and we are delighted that you took
the time out of your
very busy schedule to speak to us and we
look forward
to actually um treating you
and saying a big thank you in person to
you with a very nice reception
and so here's to a virtual
uh um reception and
a promise to um provide you with
a real one so let's all take the
take time to uh give him a round of
applause with either
our clap buttons or unmute ourselves and
just
clap and say thank you thank you very
much so this also
closes our uh frankie program events for
the season
so we look forward to seeing you um in
the new year
meanwhile here's wishing everyone a very
happy healthy holiday season
bye bye everybody thank you thank you